de la ciboulette du persil et de la mode
ça sent bon et en plus c'est très frais
on croirait une capsule de des confiné
et pourtant je peux vous assurer que la
température à l'intérieur de ma bouche
n'a pas diminué d'un seul petit degré en
fait la surface de notre langue est
recouverte de récepteurs qui se lie aux
molécules sapides contenus dans les
aliments ce qui leur donne du coup ça
fonctionne un peu comme un jeu de clés
de serrure il existe aussi des
récepteurs sensibles à la pression au
chaud et au froid
si nous avons cette sensation de
fraîcheur quand on troque le fuck demain
ou en buvant une boisson aromatisée à la
menthe
c'est tout simplement parce que le
menthol ne composés chimiques contenus
dans la plante se lie aux mêmes
récepteurs que ce sensible au froid le
cerveau reçoit la même information que
si nous procure un gala soit en fait
c'est un leurre un trompe l'oeil ou
plutôt à trompe langue voire à trompe
cerner si vous avez aimé cette capsule
n'hésitez pas à laisser un pouce bleu
vous pouvez également voir ou revoir
celle des jours précédents en cliquant
sur le côté gauche jean publie une
nouvelle chaque jour alors pour être sûr
de ne louper aucune et bien abonnez-vous
est activé et la petite cloche à demain
et n'oubliez pas nous sommes tous
confinés nom reste en lien